and Hathaway is a babbling idiot
this cancellation is a long time coming
Hathaway's appearance this week on The
View has uh I think finally provided me
the opportunity that I've been waiting
for if we agree here let's watch now the
devilish product didn't turn 16 this
summer yes the time flies boy so you
wrote this on Instagram it's the same
lady that complained about covid she
couldn't like fly to Italy Italy I don't
want to go to Italy for four years I
haven't been able to make it because of
the pandemic oh yeah this is uh Joy
Behar and she is all she does is Bash on
Trump she can't get the word Trump out
of her mouth that's all she talks about
and she just makes these ridiculous
comments and this horrible commentary
and liberal [ __ ] that is not based
in fact and yes she complained because
during covert lockdowns she couldn't go
to Italy poor thing poor thing quote I
am struck by the fact that the young
female characters in this movie built
their lives and careers in a country
then honored their right to have Choice
over their own reproductive Health see
you in the fight so why did you write
that why was it important to a free to
you to write something like that because
we're in the fight yeah we're in the
fight every day we're in the fight every
minute and you mentioned
some 16 year old's life has been
irrevocably changed yeah because of the
current overturning of Roe v Wade and in
this character I played a young woman
who was starting out her career and when
you are a young woman starting out your
career your reproductive Destiny matter
is a great deal of course and I just
what does that mean in your reproductive
Destiny matters when you're starting
like if you if you get pregnant like
you're screwed it takes all personal
responsibility for who you spread your
legs for and it puts it in the hands of
destiny destiny destiny instead of
having like it's your responsibility it
just like randomly got pregnant and
there was just like randomly not a
condom you didn't have a choice to have
an IUD or take birth control or use a
condom or all of the above if you really
wanted to be sure that you didn't get
pregnant it's as if you did didn't have
that choice you didn't it didn't yeah
productive Destiny is is is is in
Jeopardy she's mother Mary you never
know sometimes you just get pregnant
imagine if Mother Mary had had an
abortion
oh God
it had just happened and I just I think
about it all the time I think we all
think about it all the time and um and
what's implications are and what it
means to live in a country that puts us
in this position nobody put you in that
position okay yes in the very rare case
of incest and rape we're talking about
less than one percent isn't even is an
overstatement okay 99 of abortions that
happen are because the child is
inconvenient so stop pretending that
anyone put you in that position okay I'm
just so sick of the rhetoric around it
you know it's the way they talk about it
it's pro-abortion it's not pro-choice
that's what I that's legit how it is it
is and it's and it's disgusting that
they take zero personal responsibility
for the fact that they got pregnant and
I understand I get it like this is a
really [ __ ] up thing when you're you
weren't planning a pregnancy and and
here you are you know like it's it's a
super for stressful situation but let's
not make this about a clump of cells and
let's not make this about you know
people taking control of your body you
had control of your body the whole time
the whole time got some water stuck in
my ear oh okay me and Matt are on the
same page let's go again yeah yeah again
and so if I were to play that role
nowadays I couldn't take that for
granted I couldn't take that freedom for
granted the freedom of choice and by the
way I'm not this is not a moral
conversation about abortion right this
is a practical conversation about
women's rights and by the way human
rights because women's rights are humans
don't get into human rights because that
baby's a human because don't tell me you
care about human rights no I'm done I'm
done listening to it and I have been
pro-choice my entire adult life always
pro-choice always supported it in in
voting and in conversation but the past
few years yeah the way they push it is
disgusting no I agree it's like they
push abortions it's wild they don't they
don't even talk about
self-accountability it's crazy tell me
human rights you want to talk human
rights you better include that baby
cells like two months in there's like a
mother in one room fighting to save the
baby and then the other room [ __ ]
killing it at the same age it's like
that's crazy to me let's keep going it's
sad and the freedom that we all need to
be able to to choose and build our lives
and have access to excellent health care
I bet you spent two thousand dollars on
her [ __ ] hairdo okay right you know
what take that money Anne and go install
that's for women you could help five
women you could help get an IUD so that
they don't have to go through the
atrocity of an abortion because I don't
know a single woman that's been through
an abortion that hasn't tried over it
and doesn't still cry over years later
okay stop making it seem like it's you
know it's okay I mean you have friends
that have had abortions does it just
like [ __ ] them up like big time yes it
just like [ __ ] them up like and it
never goes away it comes you know it
goes away it goes in the back like
painful things do and then it rises up
here and there it's trauma I don't think
I could get married or anything to her
view of the woman that had an abortion I
feel like it would just that's like oh
here there's like the body count thing
like yeah that's that's not good if you
slept over the million people we already
we [ __ ] talk about this all day I'm
sure you guys watch fresh and frit and
Tate I need to go on whole tangent about
that but like she gets an abortion
that's like get the [ __ ] out of there
you know you know what I don't am I
really wrong there I don't think it's
that black and white I really think it
depends on where that woman was at the
time where she is at the time that you
met her she may come to you and say this
is the worst thing I you know that she
feels terrible about it and she regrets
it and she never wants to live that way
again and she may be the most solid
woman you've ever met yeah
that's just like you're not gonna she's
the mower thrower to the dogs because of
that like you it there it's way more
it's way more complicated than that
sunny and again I've been pro-choice
forever but this conversation around
acting like I'm just saying there's red
flags and that's like that's like a
[ __ ] that's a that's a red flag why
am I like it how is that crazy to say
like yeah there's a chance she's the
greatest woman I ever met but it's like
no I'm saying in theory assuming we have
all facts on the table right yes it is a
red flag it depends on the circumstances
who she was and who she is if she's
still the same [ __ ] and you know that
just sleeps around and used it that used
abortion as birth control yeah it's not
even just about that it's like a genuine
I just think it like it would [ __ ] a
woman up to do something like that and
like you just said the same thing yeah
like it's just like they're [ __ ] up
for years even when a woman has like a
miscarriage like that's not like it it
it [ __ ] go they go crazy a lot of the
time and that was like it's traumatizing
well exactly it's like you're it's kind
of the same thing it's the same clump of
cells that's getting ripped out of your
body you know what I'm saying maybe I'm
tripping let's keep going if you listen
to any leftists when they talk about
abortion or really any other subject at
all all that any of them do is Babble
incoherently she says that uh Grieves
her to consider that the young female
characters in Devil Wears Prada would
not be able to have abortions if the
film was set in the current day it is to
begin with extremely strange to worry
about the availability of abortion for
fictional characters
um now I've never seen The Devil Wears
Prada but I'm pretty sure that the film
is largely set in New York women in New
York can still get abortion unless they
don't exist because they're fictional
which is a logistical problem that will
prevent them from doing a lot of things
including getting abortions also again
not having seen it my impression is that
the movie has a rather dim view of
selfish career-obsessed people um that's
like the Devil Wears Prada that's so
part of the moral of the story from what
I understand is that there's more to
life than professional ambition yet
Hathaway's takeaway is that women need
to be able to kill their children so
they can focus more on career
advancement there seems to be a little
bit of a disconnect she also speaks
about reproductive Destiny which of
course is exactly the sort of asinine
hackneyed phrase you would expect Anne
Hathaway to use when discussing abortion
it's not the sort of wording that I
would ever choose but since she brought
it up let us ask this question
reproductive Destiny Okay well once a
woman has conceived a child what is her
reproductive Destiny the word destiny
implies a force outside of the
individual a message a mission from
Beyond ourselves so what is this Force
call it nature call it the universe call
it as I do God what is this Force trying
to say to the woman damn
I didn't even think of that that is
crazy right God it's like watching
obviously this is your destiny to have
this child it's like watching evil isn't
that crazy like this is like Antichrist
like you're watching it hurts me so much
[ __ ] I didn't even think about that
women find every possible Turner phrase
that they can to justify killing a child
because it was inconvenient you know it
used to be like you you weren't around
when I was young and abortion was if you
had a successful kid it used to be like
it's celebrated because they died so
much it's not even that's not what I was
doing like when a woman had an abortion
in the 80s and the 90s and even the
2000s it was extremely extremely painful
it was secretive you had to find your
friend who you trusted more than anybody
that wouldn't tell anybody that would be
discreet that would take care of you
because you were hurting physically and
emotionally before during and after it
was so it was so used in a way that was
just like only in an emergency and it
hurt for a woman to have to do that I've
told you that I have taken two different
women to the clinic and I didn't know
that I have participated into that
extent I never have had an abortion but
the only time I was pregnant was with
you so I participated twice and it is
extremely excruciating for everybody
even for me like I carry that weight
with me because I saw what my friends
went through and it was really difficult
and you know now it's just become this
flip it's my right it's the Columbus
cells they make tick tocks about it
celebrities tweet just had another
abortion yay me women's rights you [ __ ]
you you sick sick [ __ ] it's one thing to
say you know we we need this because you
know some women are put in a bad spot
but to make it like it's glorious and
it's good and it's something about
controlling our destiny and it's a human
right [ __ ] you it's not a human right to
kill another human period it's wild it's
like they said you were not even like
the biggest like pro-life people but the
way they portray it is just horrible you
feel like you have to stand against this
evil because it is like it feels like a
genuinely evil force oh my God you can
get an abortion 24 weeks in they're
fighting for their fight for full-term
abortions which is when the baby's like
about to be born when the baby is viable
the baby can survive outside of the womb
they're still fighting to have that baby
aborted if the mother so chooses and
they did research you can look it up at
on the National Institute of Health in
the CDC this isn't like [ __ ]
right-wing crazy research it's
Government research they tried to figure
out what happened in late term abortions
why they were being had because the
media will tell you it's to save the
life of the mother
no or in an emergency no we're talking
late term so they will tell you that
it's because of those things but
overwhelmingly in almost every single
case in a late term abortion it was for
the exact same reasons as the early term
abortions which was inconvenience so
don't let them tell you that we need
late-term abortion in order to save
anyone's life because it's just not
[ __ ] true and the data and the
science has is behind it the research is
behind it you need to start following
Abby Johnson she is a pro-life activist
who was the director of a Planned
Parenthood Center and she oversaw and
even had her she she had abortions
herself she oversaw hundreds of
abortions and then she she started to
get more involved in the abortions and
seeing what was going on in the room
with the baby how it was all going down
and she flipped out and is now the
single most prominent pro-life activist
in America holy [ __ ] she's a big deal
Abby Johnson I gotta look into that
that's crazy is it her Destiny to
partake in the joy and beauty and
fulfillment of motherhood or is it her
Destiny to pay some abortionist to kill
her baby and throw his body into a
medical waste dumpster I would say the
former indeed how could it be anyone's
reproductive Destiny to reject their
reproductive capacity and violently
destroy the human life that they have
reproduced to call such a choice
reproductive Destiny seems uh bizarre to
say the least Hathaway also claims that
she's not interested in having a moral
conversation about abortion but rather a
practical conversation about women's
rights well except that a conversation
about rights is automatically a
conversation about morality you cannot
extract the concept of morality from the
concept of Human Rights a practical
conversation a real practical
conversation is one that is not
concerned with theories or ideas at all
hope Ann sees this yeah not that it'll
change your minds because I don't think
she's got enough brain cells for it but
human rights are a theory they are yeah
they're a moral idea that isn't to say
they don't exist but rather that they
exist in the moral realm they don't
exist physically practically like a
chair or a rock or the ocean exists so
to say that you don't want to talk about
morality you just want to talk about
human rights that is to speak gibberish
human rights are a moral concept the
minute you bring them up you have
entered into the moral realm but that's
not where Anne Hathaway wants to be
because she knows that she can't
actually defend abortion on moral
grounds none of these people can and
that's the issue but she had more to say
and it only gets dumber from here so
let's continue
another thing and just without going to
too many details my own personal
experience with abortion and I don't
think we talk about this enough abortion
can be another word for Mercy we don't
know we don't know it's not a world in
which we know that no two pregnancies
are alike and it follows that no two
lives are like that follows that no two
conceptions are alike so how can we have
a law how can we have a point of view on
this that says we must treat everything
the same and where I come at it from is
when you allow for choice you allow for
flexibility which is what we need in
order to be human so that anyway I just
wanted to include all right
especially for that it's not it's not
set in stone just being able to have an
abortion is what makes you human like
you hear this [ __ ] because uh no two
pregnancies are the same and this
pregnancy may not work out so I might as
well just kill it what because you get
pregnant doesn't mean you get to keep
that baby yeah it's a health decision
and it can be it really can be at least
she calls it a baby at least she called
it a baby how do you actually call it a
baby and then still defend smooshing it
smushing it abortion is another word for
Mercy she says but Mercy For Whom Mercy
for the child who's being killed that's
not Mercy John has an entire life ahead
of him or he should you're taking that
away You're deciding for him that his
life is not worth living you're erasing
all of his potential all that could have
been and you're not giving him a choice
in the matter there's no mercy in that
it's the opposite of Mercy because it's
the opposite of empathy and you can't
have mercy without empathy or do you
mean that it's merciful to the woman are
you saying that killing a child is an
act of Mercy to the child's mother well
no mercy to the mother is to help her to
give her the resources she needs Mercy
is what pregnancy centers provide Mercy
is their Ministries what they do
abortion clinics on the other hand are
vultures they prey on fear and misery
they cash in on it they feed off of it
they profit off of it they sell guilt
they sell regret they sell loneliness
while taking away the love and joy of
motherhood that's not Mercy it's
mercenary so whichever way Hathaway
meant it she's
isn't that crazy that all these
businesses like there's people profiting
off of them oh yeah like there's someone
who's like making money off of people
having abortions and then they're
incentivized to destroy the stigma of
abortions that way they make more money
like it's that's the [ __ ] Matrix
right there and that's with every
business same thing with like
Pharmaceuticals like the doctors used to
literally be told what drugs to give
people because it made those companies
money they still are like that I've been
used to it imagine yeah yeah you're
right but like imagine thinking you're
going to a doctor where they have like
the most like the best information for
you to help you and it's all just so
that's what it used to be so doctors
used to make decisions
limited tools before pharmaceutical
companies you know became this massive
money making machines and they it used
to be that you could trust that the
doctor was making the best decision
based on what he knew now you can trust
that the doctor is making the best
decision based on what he knows plus
what the pharmaceutical companies are
incentivizing him or her to to give you
do you remember when we were talking
with Uncle Chris at dinner and he was
like so our uncle or my uncle had um an
aneurysm while he was in where was he
taught
um Indonesia he was in Asia
he had an aneurysm in Asia and he was at
the hospital he got flu he flew to India
to get to a better hospital and he was
there for like what maybe a few weeks
and the bill was like 500 000 for the
few weeks and I'm like I'm asking him
I'm like what the [ __ ] did they do to
you did Jesus come down and kiss your
foot like what happened and he's like
well you know I had like good service
and the food was I'm like the food and
service the nurse makes forty thousand
dollars in there she probably makes like
twenty thousand dollars a year a half a
million dollars why him in a private
chat yeah okay the jet from Singapore to
Mumbai because he was unconscious that
wasn't because of the aneurysm he
couldn't fly high so he had to fly at a
low altitude so that had to be at least
twenty thirty thousand right 500
000 though for the time at the hospital
like I couldn't wrap my head around them
like where the [ __ ] is this money going
though I'm not sure she knows how she
meant it because she's just babbling
which is what most defenses of abortion
boil down to incoherent Babel yeah and
that is why Ann Hathaway is today
finally after all these years canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show so we'll do it for this I'm gonna
that's my new outro that'll do it for
this portion of the sunny Fez and Mom
show if you want to subscribe you can
hit the button below my Instagram is
linked in the description if you want to
learn Tech talk and how to make money
online you can join my Discord I have
some free tips you can learn some things
there you can write your social media
destiny
gone
[Music]
[Music]